the movie begins in the year 1050 with a
group of Viking ships heading to raid a
monastery in Normandy despite the Mon's
pleas the Vikings forcibly enter a
secret chamber believing that it holds a
valuable treasure however their
assumption proves incorrect as they
discover a wolf cub hidden behind a
locked door as compensation for the
absent gold and silver the Vikings
decide to take the Cub with them to
Norway but by the time their ship
reaches the Norwegian Coast all the men
are killed by the wolf which then
escapes into the Wilderness the scene
then fast forwards when thousand years
and we are introduced to tale Berg a
17-year-old girl living with her family
in the Norwegian town of nio the family
seems to have recently moved here
because if her mother lives transferred
to the local police force it is revealed
that her father passed away some months
ago tail indirectly blames her mother
for her father's death and does not get
along well with her stepfather Arthur
the only person she is still close with
and cares for is her deaf little sister
named Jenny one day while watching a
horror movie with Jenny tail receives a
text message from her high school friend
Jonas he inv invites her to a party in
the woods near the bay along with other
NBO youth as a result she informs her
stepfather and sets off on her bicycle
upon arrival she starts conversing with
yonas one of their fellow schoolmates
named elen who is the local mayor's
daughter becomes jealous of their
closeness and takes yonas away for a
private talk this makes poor tail feel
unwanted so she decides to leave early
as she heads back she stumbles upon
yanas and elen talking in the Woods by
the bay suddenly a dark creature attacks
elen leaving her severely injured yonas
runs away in fear while tail rushes to
help elen but she gets injured herself
as the creature slices her shoulder
following this elen is dragged into the
woods ultimately leading to her demise
sometime later the local police and
paramedics arrive at the scene yonas and
tail receive medical attention while the
police force led by Tail's mother and
police chief eert start their
investigation they search for elen but
only find a blood covered cell phone and
a large torn claw later that night Liv
researches the claw's characteristics on
the internet leading her to suspect that
the creature may be a wolf the next day
all people who attended the party are
questioned by the police including yonas
and tale as key eyewitnesses however
they are completely unaware of what kind
of creature attacked them in the
meantime elen's mutilated body is found
deeper in the woods and sent for an
autopsy the examination reveals that
something big attacked her although it
is still unclear if it was a wolf the
forensic expert reports that the
creature dragged her far enough as many
pieces of Flesh are missing from her
body in order to confirm the creature
the police force calls in the help of an
expert from the Veterinary College named
William before that a mysterious
one-armed man named Lars visits the
police station and asks permission to
meet the chief of police shortly after
he speaks with Liv and shares his belief
that the creature is a werewolf a hybrid
of a human and a wolf he claims to have
dedicated his life to tracking this
creature throughout Scandinavia Lars
also asserts that this werewolf comes
out during full moon nights and craves
human blood unfortunately Liv doesn't
believe the man and dismisses him she
believes that he is a drunk who is
talking rubbish despite this slar gives
her a silver bullet emphasizing that it
is the only weapon capable of killing
the beast in the evening yonas summons
tail to a restaurant and apologizes for
involving her in the incident in
response tail Comforts him explaining
that no one should bear blame for what
occurred after a brief conversation tail
walks out and stumbles upon elen's
friends who accuse her of cowardice and
failing to help their friend this deeply
upsets tail prompting her to cycle back
home seeing her in a disturbed State Liv
attempts to talk to her but tail does
doesn't want to listen the following day
William arrives at the police station
and begins his examination of elen's
corpse based on the injuries of the
victim and the claw found on the scene
the vet concludes that it is an
unusually large wolf with this
information in hand Liv and eer hire a
hunting force and set out into the woods
with the intent of killing the creature
unless it turns out to be a hot teen
with a six-pack upon their arrival the
hunting Force Under The Joint leadership
of Liv and eer begins their search with
the help of a tracking dog as they
Venture deeper into the forest they
stumble upon a headless corpse which is
identified as an asylum Seeker
recognizing the severity of the
situation Liv calls for additional
backup she assigns two Hunters to remain
and guard the body until backup arrives
while she and the rest of the team
proceed further after a while of walking
the group comes across an abandoned cave
Liv decides to investigate it so she
cautiously makes her way inside she soon
discovers a dark M shaft with a ladder
that leads downward as she descends she
is momentarily startled when she finds
the missing head of the body they found
her earlier meanwhile the hunters
guarding the corpse hear a menacing Roar
before they can react the creature
launches a surprise attack resulting in
their unfortunate deaths the rest of the
team hears their screams and soon after
the creature closes in on them it claims
the lives of two more members of The
Hunting Party and inflicts serious
injuries upon eyer Liv hurriedly climbs
out of the mine but comes face to face
with the creature at the top of the
ladder at this moment the true nature of
the creature is revealed it is indeed a
wolf the wolf lunges at her causing her
to Tumble back into the M shaft this
injures her wrist prompting her to
scream in pain as Liv crawls away from
the advancing wolf she manages to grab
her gun and Fires at it but the bullet
appears to have no effect on it soon Liv
runs out of ammo leaving her at the
mercy of the wolf but just then she
remembers the Silver Bullet given to her
by Lars acting swiftly she loads it into
her gun and Fires at the wolf killing it
once and for all in the next scene Liv
wakes up in the hospital where her
injured wrist is placed in a cast eyert
on the other hand is revealed to be in a
coma and tragically none of the other
Hunters survived in the midst of all
these events tail begins experiencing
peculiar dreams and Visions causing
considerable mental distress one day at
school her hearing senses suddenly
sharpen allowing her to hear even the
sound of yonas sketching with his pencil
this leaves her at Great unease
prompting her to hastily Retreat to the
restroom even there she hears a crying
voice coming from behind a restroom door
as she cautiously approaches to
investigate she encounters The
Apparition of the island accusing her of
letting her die how however the figure
vanishes revealing it to be her
hallucination later that night tail
experiences sleepwalking but thankfully
Jenny guides her safely back to her bed
the next day William examines the wolf's
body in the laboratory after a thorough
assessment he informs Liv that the
regular lead bullets she used had no
effect on the wolf despite hitting its
heart and lungs the only fatal injury
inflicted upon the wolf came from the
Silver Bullet which she fired last this
Revelation shocks Liv and she realizes
that it is indeed a werewolf that night
tail receives a text message from yonas
asking if she wants to meet in response
she sneaks out of her house and meets
him at a Viewpoint as they Converse tail
confides and her friend about her recent
unsettling experiences she mentions that
she has never felt this scared in all
her life yanis attempts to comfort her
encouraging her to move on from the
traumatic incident he also reassures her
that the threat has been wiped out their
conversation gradually takes a romantic
turn and they end up sharing a romantic
kiss after a while yonas receives a call
from his father while he steps away to
answer the phone ta has her gaze locked
on the full moon which traditionally
triggers werewolf Transformations she
starts feeling uneasy and eventually
turns into a more animalistic version of
herself with sharp teeth and animal-like
instincts when Jonas returns to her
after her call he discovers her on the
ground before she can warn him she loses
control and kills him the following
morning tail awakens in her House's
garage and is scared to find blood
smeared across her face she also vomits
up a piece of her friend's finger
indicating that she devoured him the
previous night however she has no
recollection of what transpired or what
she did to her friend troubled by this
she heads to the Viewpoint only to
discover that the police are in the
process of removing Jonas's mutilated
body later after an examination of the
body William concludes that the injuries
sustained by yonus are similar to those
of Island but it was caused by a smaller
creature following this Liv decides to
seek additional information about
werewolves from Lars the latter explains
that once a human undergo the
transformation into a wolf they no
longer have any Humanity left in them
the only way to break the curse is to
put an end to the entire bloodline of
werewolves on the other hand tail
realizes that she has now become a
threat to everyone around her so she
makes the decision to leave
unfortunately while on the bus the full
moon breaks through the clouds
triggering her transformation into a
full-fledged wolf tail then proceeds to
attack the other passengers which causes
the bus to crash in a tunnel before long
Liv arrives at the scene and encounters
survivors running away from the bus she
grabs her weapon and cautiously
approaches the wreckage but the wolf
appears to have already departed leaving
behind a scene of Carnage during her
brief inspection of the bus LIF spots
her daughter's torn clothing as well as
her locket just then William arrives at
the scene with shocking information he
explains that after analyzing the wolf's
body he has detected human DNA this
confirms that they are dealing with an
actual werewolf hearing this Liv
realizes that her daughter has now
become the new werewolf in the next
scene taale in her fully transformed
State returns home and approaches Jenny
the two come face to face but the
werewolf seems to recognize her sister
nevertheless Tail's stepfather
intervenes and fights her using a lamp
as a makeshift weapon he manages to take
Jenny to their car and speed away but
unfortunately Arthur appears to have
been bitten by the wolf during the
confrontation causing him to lose a lot
of blood due to this he eventually
passes out behind the wheel resulting in
a deadly car crash as the crowd notices
the accident they approach the crashed
vehicle to help but they soon fall
victim to tail the werewolf then goes on
a murder spree and devours their flesh
witnessing this tragic scene Jenny takes
matters into her own hands and bravely
walks towards tail she attempts to
calmer sister down and for a moment she
is successful in doing so but soon after
Liv and William arrive on the scene with
William using a tranquilizer dart to
subdue the wolf while Liv rushes to grab
Jenny the trio then seeks refuge in an
empty store to protect themselves as
they struggle to keep tail out Liv
orders Jenny to hide behind the counter
just then Lars arrives in his RV and
crashes through the store's front
entrance in an attempt to hit tail this
Reckless action leaves Liv William and
Lars seriously injured but tail is still
unharmed the werewolf proceeds to kill
Lars and then launches an attack on Liv
Liv uses all her strength to hold tail
off by using her wrist cast as a shield
as the werewolf bites down on it Liv
orders an injured William to shoot
another tranquilizer dart realizing that
William is in no condition to help Jenny
takes the dart and stabs it into her
sister's side putting an end to the
attack in the aftermath tail is seen
confined in the veterinary clinic in an
unconscious State Liv pays a visit and
apologizes to her for not taking proper
care of her but now that tail poses a
great threat Liv reluctantly loads her
gun with a silver bullet and places it
against Tail's neck subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching